c'était un bâtiment emblématique de
dijon les usines terreau deux hectares
et demi de friches industrielles le long
du boulevard voltaire de ses imposants
bâtiments
il ne reste aujourd'hui presque plus
rien à part cette façade des années 30
dernier vestige de la saga terreau dans
ce bâtiment là au rez-de-chaussée de
l'usinage avait des grosses machines
premier étage deuxième étage en a mais
l'assemblage des vélos et au dernier
étage stockage de pièces détachées et
puis la chaîne des maillages pour les
pièces métalliques
c'est un symbole on va dire de ce qui a
été terreau ça me laissera une trace de
l'empreinte
à la fois de ce qui s'est passé entre
les murs puis à la fois des gens qui ont
travaillé tout simplement quoi pour
l'association arbre à cames
ce chantier c'est la dernière page de
l'histoire de terreau une histoire
commencée dès 1887 dans ses ateliers
six cent mille motos seront construites
jusqu'au milieu du xxème siècle terreau
c'était une grande entreprise qui a fait
travailler énormément de monde sur dijon
c'était aussi le moyen de locomotion de
pratiquement tous les gens dans les
années 30 c'est quand même un nom qui
nationalement connus et c'est l'une des
entreprises qui a fabriqué le plus de
motos sur le territoire et pour
transmettre cette histoire aux futures
générations
l'association prévoit d'installer un
petit musée sur le site
mais d'ici 2024 c'est avant tout un
vaste projet immobilier qui verra le
jour cette partie là vous aurez des
logements 317 logements ensuite derrière
le bâtiment historique l'école spéciale
d'architecturé et de l'autre côté de
l'école spéciale d'architecturé la
résidence seniors l'ehpad et la
résidence étudiants le chantier de
démolition se terminera d'ici fin mai
les nouveaux bâtiments sortiront de
terre dès l'été prochain